yes lots of joy in giving and expressing
love absolutely but don't buy in to the
capitalistic because this is
what will happen is there will be
another holiday that comes up and there
will be the oh well I'm not a worthy
boyfriend or husband or whatever
son or or father or whatever if
I don't or mother or whatever if I don't
uh AC crew T of thousand thousands
hundreds thousands tens of thousands or
even more dollars to buy this this
special gift it's all just
it's it's all
propagandistic and it
just hooked it's just hooked
it's just
hooked and the body is just autonomously
moving to fulfill a sense of
lack that's not there and then just that
little bit of here's a video
here's the question where are you going
is just like softening that where am I
going what is this what
is
[Music]
oh ah I don't actually lack
anything I'm already
whole
huh damn I just want to play I just want
to have fun I just want to be joyous and
be innocent and build holistically for
the future of all children to be
abundant and free